executive branch and presidential
misconduct
check your program guide for more
information
now here's peter andreas
okay good afternoon pardon me good
afternoon i'm ed steinfeld i'm the
director of the watson institute for
international and public affairs
and i am so delighted to be here today
to celebrate
killer hives fantastic new book by peter
andreas let me just say as a student of
chinese affairs
i hardly need to be told about
the importance of the relationship
between drugs and war i of course know
the intensity of feelings in china about
the century of humiliation that began
with the
opium war um
but at the same time it's it's easy for
a lot of people including myself to
think of something like the opium war as
a maybe an anomaly or something very
particular to a very particular time and
place and i have to say i'm i'm guilty
of thinking about the opium war that way
but
great scholarship truly great
scholarship
like killer high like a lot of the work
that's done here at the watson institute
forces us forces me
to see the world in a totally new way
this book
has forced me and i think it forces all
readers to to really focus on the
eternal and incredibly expansive
relationship
between drugs and war
that relationship extends
from war conducted by people who are
often on a form of drug some kind of of
um psychoactive substance it extends to
wars and conquest of drugs or the raw
materials for drugs it extends to wars
for
markets and and for outlets for drugs
and of course as we're all familiar with
wars against drugs but as peter argues
so effectively this um phenomenon this
interaction between psychoactive
substances and conflict just is laced
throughout history and right up to the
present
uh peter
makes a number of very interesting
conclusions in this book but also raises
a number of questions and i think we're
going to have an opportunity today with
this fantastic panel to delve into some
of those questions which will again
emphasize this entirely new lens that
peter gives us to see the world let me
quickly explain how we're going to
proceed i'm going to ask peter to come
up and speak for 10 minutes or so about
the book and then i'm going to ask our
panelists each to comment
for 10 minutes or so each on the book
and then we're going to open it up to
questions and answers
if you will let me briefly introduce
peter and our and our panelists
peter andreas is the john hay professor
of international studies here at the
watson institute and at the department
of political science he's the author
co-author co-editor of 11 books
including of course killer high but also
the 2013 book smuggler nation how
illicit trade made america of course
quite relevant today as we talk about we
live in a world of trade frictions and
talk about piracy and make claims about
a variety of countries illicit
activities
next to speak will be chris chivers
who is a pulitzer prize-winning
long-form writer and journalist for the
new york times i'm sure many of you all
of you are familiar with his work i'm a
big fan
he's worked at the new york times since
1999. his career as a foreign
correspondent has focused on conflict
regions spanning afghanistan iraq the
palestinian territories chechnya libya
and syria among others
chris also served as a marine corps
infantryman a combat veteran from the
first gulf war the persian gulf war
next
to speak will be angelica duran martinez
who is associate professor of political
science at the university of
massachusetts lowell
angelica is a 2013 phd recipient from
brown
and she is a
noted expert on latin american and
comparative politics but with a
particular emphasis on organized crime
and criminality illicit markets and the
relationship between state actors and
non-state actors often armed non-state
actors she's the author of the
award-winning 2018 book the politics of
drug violence criminals cops and
politicians in colombia and mexico that
that
was from oxford university press and
stephen kinser
well known to everybody here is a senior
fellow at the watson institute and of
course an award-winning journalist who
over the course of his career covered
more than 50 countries on five
continents
stephen spent more than 20 years working
for the new york times as a foreign
correspondent and bureau chief and among
his numerous acclaimed books
uh include the 2019 volume poisoner in
chief sydney gottlieb and the cia search
for mind control obviously topical for
the discussion today
so with that let me turn the microphone
over to peter andreas
congrats
okay well thank you all for coming
if you are here because you think this
is about the made for tv
dvds um
killer high
i'm sorry to disappoint you
um
i'm sure that dvd has and will outsell
my book um
the genre for that i believe listed on
amazon is
is horror
slash
comedy so this my book is definitely
horror there's not a lot of comedy
um in it in fact
the title killer eye has grown on me it
wasn't my selection my choice for title
originally was the subtitle of the book
a history of war
in six drugs and let me just give you
a few highlights of the book
what i try to do
in a mere 300 some pages
is retell the history of warfare through
the lens
of drugs and retell the history
of drugs through the lens of war
and hopefully for those of you who end
up reading the book you'll not quite
think of war again in the same way and
you won't quite think of drugs
in the same way in fact i'd like to
convince you that drugs and war grew up
together and over time became
quite addicted
to each other a one-liner would be drugs
made war
and war
made drugs
these two things tend to be treated
quite separately
in the literatures on war and drugs and
so what i do is systematically try to
tie them
uh together across time
across place
and across psychoactive substance
the motivation for the book was
not history it was to bring history into
what i consider a
policy debate that suffers from a severe
case of historical amnesia
a debate about the so-called
nexus between drugs and conflict we
talked today about narco states
and the first thing that comes to mind
is afghanistan
we think about narco insurgents or narco
terrorists we think about colombia and
maybe also again afghanistan
but looked at this issue from a much
deeper
historical sweep going back not just
years and decades but even centuries
the first true narco state
is probably great britain
in first in fact great britain is
probably the first
narco empire if you think about the
sheer importance of
alcohol taxes the importance of the tea
trade that's a powerful drug i'm
addicted to it it's called nicotine i
mean uh caffeine not nicotine don't
touch the stuff
um
or the importance of the opium trade
for the rise of britain as the world's
foremost maritime
power
in fact narco insurgents
yes it's the farc yes it's the taliban
but it was also george washington
why do i say george washington well
that
conflict very much depended on revenue
generated by tobacco
in fact got a loan from france based on
tobacco revenue and the brits were so
upset about it they burned tobacco
fields whenever they found them
including tobacco fields owned by thomas
jefferson
so what i try to do in this book is
systematically
unravel interrogate unpack
the relationship between drugs
and war and i actually find there's five
relationships
one is war while on drugs literally
combatant drug use
in wartime but not just combatant but
also
on the home front as well drug use by
civilians dealing with coping with
wartime
obviously war is stressful work
no surprise that drugs
help soldiers cope
they also help them celebrate victories
they help them prepare for battle they
give them liquid courage after all
i also talk about war
through drugs
totally different than war while on
drugs war through drugs meaning using
drugs primarily to fund war
that ranges from
alcon tobacco taxes to
cocaine and opium
revenue the full gamut from licit
to illicit drugs
natural
to semi-synthetic to fully synthetic
drugs
from the most benign to the most
dangerous
psychoactive substances
then there's war for drugs which is
actually distinct from the first two
warfare drugs is actually going to war
over drug markets and as ed already
mentioned um
the most famous case of this of course
are the opium wars of the mid 19th
century where britain
forced opium onto china through the
barrel of a gun
but it goes all the way up to the
present if we think about
what's going on in mexico today more
people have died in mexico
since late 2006 than have died in iraq
and afghanistan combined
drug violence that
although security analysts are reluctant
to call it
war
if you actually look at the sheer number
of casualties
if you look at how
well-armed
the perpetrators are using
military-grade equipment actually the
actors themselves are often militarily
trained often defectors from the
military in one case
u.s trained anti-drug force turned into
a drug hit squad for drug trafficking
organizations
and then you think about that the state
itself has deployed its military
in a front-running role in fighting
drugs the mexican military is
essentially an anti-drug force at this
point
and then you say it's not just mexico
but also colombia to some extent and
also brazil to some extent and even the
united states since the 1980s has
loosened the posse comitatus act which
restricted the use of the us military
for law enforcement purposes
now very much
uh embedded in the war on drugs um
at the border and beyond and just the
proliferation also of militarized
policing in our own community swat teams
swat teams were invented before the war
on drugs but really took off thanks to
the war on drugs and this is using
military technologies often military
ex-military personnel
and approaches
to fighting
a substance
there's the war against drugs
which
is closely related but distinct then war
4 drugs were against drugs started as a
metaphor
nixon declared war against drugs
he didn't actually send in troops
to fight drugs
but since the 1980s uh it's become
progressively more
militarized so that we could actually
call it an outright war
and last but not least and this is
probably the research in the book that
most surprised me
is drugs after war how much war itself
left a lasting legacy in terms of drug
production trafficking
regulation
drug tastes
have been fundamentally altered
thanks to wars in ways that we often
don't give war credit for
just give you a few examples
why are we a coffee drinking rather than
a tea drinking nation
because we won the american revolution
the brits went on with tea
we turned to coffee
we not only turned to coffee we turned
to whiskey
rum was the drink of choice produced
right here in rhode island
before the american revolution
the distilleries which kept much of
rhode island going including in
massachusetts
never revived after the american
revolution and whiskey
became the alcoholic beverage of choice
it was a
national drink it would no longer needed
imports from abroad it was considered
patriotic to turn to whiskey turn
against that british drink
rum turn against that british drink tea
so our very tastes that we now just take
for granted are actually a result
of war
the very criminalization of cocaine
is a product of world war ii very few
people remember that cocaine was legally
produced by japanese pharmaceutical
companies coca grown in java
the destruction
of
those fields and the destruction of the
japanese pharmaceutical cocaine industry
is part of the u.s victory in world war
ii the us had turned against cocaine
much earlier of course but it wasn't
only with the victory of japan that the
u.s was actually able to globalize
its preference
for cocaine prohibition so cocaine was
actually one of the biggest losers legal
cocaine was one of the biggest losers of
world war ii
illegal cocaine decades later
was arguably one of the biggest winners
so those are the five relationships now
i want to tell you just a little bit in
a few minutes that i have
what the six key drugs are and i've
already given you hints because i've
mentioned some of them
the oldest most multi-purpose and
arguably double-edged of the drugs is
alcohol
it goes back
uh it's it's to beer and wine
uh
and then the distilling revolution
really did indeed revolutionize things
think about um
just think about why france is the
world's most famous wine producing
region in the world it's
the roman conquest is what brought wine
to france bordeaux was set up
as a port by the romans
after
after the romans uh retreated in her
push back wine endures in france right
um
the distilling revolution
was absolutely essential to the conquest
of the new world think about the
importance of alcohol as an ethnic
cleanser
in westward expansion
in fact
hard alcohol became so important
that it was actually
rum rations on both sides of the
american revolution
after the revolution whiskey became part
of u.s
military rations
in fact the british
believe it or not had rum rations until
the early 1970s on their naval ships
second drug tobacco arrives much later
than alcohol but once it arrives
equally potent and in fact
none of the downsides of alcohol
alcohol basically you can raise a lot of
revenue but you also might have a drunk
military
the tsar
was able to finance the largest army
standing army in europe with vodka
revenue but his soldiers were drunk
tobacco is the ideal war drug
highly portable
fights both anxiety and boredom
relieves um
is highly taxable
and doesn't impede performance even if
it might eventually kill you
the globalization of tobacco is
intimately also about
the spread of warfare soldiers
globalized warfare and the very mode of
tobacco consumption was closely
influenced by war so why do we turn away
from
hookahs and and pipes
to cigars and then cigarettes
increasingly portable
easily to produce
to move
this was an intimate story
of war
in fact cigarettes by the time world war
ii
came around was the most valued ration
in in cigarette in soldier rations
third caffeine
my drug of choice i'm completely
addicted to the stuff
it's the most world's most popular
psychoactive substance
but certainly far from a benign
relationship to war
arguably stimulated imperial expansion i
already mentioned the british empire of
tea
but then we also have the rise of
caffeinated soldiers it's fascinating
that in the case of the u.s civil war
coffee is mentioned in soldier diaries
more often than gun cannon or rifle
right coffee is just this essential
ingredient to keep soldiers going
instant coffee
was an instant hit on the battlefield in
world war ii and then outlived world war
ii
the coffee break
was actually introduced for defense
workers during world war ii and then
outlived world war ii and
institutionalized in the workplace in
the 1950s
and then all the way up to today
the favorite beverage at military bases
across the world are hyper-caffeinated
beverages like
red bull
and
uh
monster
and so on
fourth opium
i had already mentioned opium wars are
an extreme case of the relationship
between war and drugs which is war four
uh war four drugs imperial wars but also
for example the japanese imperial
um
occupation of of china
there's no way that japan in the late
1930s could fund its occupation of china
without narcotics
an extreme case of war while on drugs
sun tzu said speed is the essence of war
he did not mean amphetamines
but he'd be pretty impressed
at how important amphetamines were
to keep soldiers on many sides going
during world war ii
and then last but not least
cocaine
the extreme case of war against drugs
which i've already said a few things
about
i'll stop there and turn things over
to chris
thank you peter uh
i'm an open with compliments if you look
at my copy
all the way through you can tell i was
engaged uh when i get to the end of the
book and i've used up two ink pens
it's probably a sign it's a hell of a
book um i was an early lucky reader
peter got me a copy over
um over christmas and i spent the
holidays with it
it's a work of history as you just heard
uh
and it history is an act of making
diverse and sometimes divergent sources
cohere into an understanding and maybe a
set of narratives
that are relatable and analyses that can
make you as you said
re-imagine
the world and understand it anew in this
case the world of war and that was my
experience of it but i don't want to
talk about history at least not distant
history um
i want to talk more about now and some
more recent observations since
um the persian gulf war of 1990 and 91
and the so-called
as the military calls it global war on
terror since 2001 and bring the events
that peter has related
up to the present time are there any
recent veterans in the room
any
no well maybe the good one and they'll
hopefully be some on c-span and you can
fact-check me with some of what i'm
going to say i welcome you to
comment afterward
but
you know we talk about what peter talks
about in the book and in his remarks the
place that various substances have on
the battlefield and the battlefields of
this
era that we live in now
have changed a bit
for modern conventional militaries the
war has become
so technical and the military commands
have become in some cases so politically
sensitive
that some of the long-standing drugs on
the battlefield are now prohibited
alcohol most notably
for a variety of reasons although
the military is a heavy user at the at
the personal level of alcohol at the
individual level at the unit level when
deployed
alcohol i'm not going to call it
non-existent but it's not
but it's almost invisible
it's quite rare it's very unusual to see
alcohol on the battlefield some of this
is because the wars as we've had them
since 2001 and since the gulf war in
fact
have often played out among islamic
populations
and there is a sensitivity to having the
military make the social faux pas of
ingesting alcohol
in a country where they have been in
some cases invited and other cases are
occupied but in any case are hoping to
get along with the population better
than what the other mice might so
there is still alcohol on the
battlefield but you won't see much of it
you got to look when i was in
in the 80s and 90s there were among the
troops i was in the marine infantry
these things called snake bite kits
which was a euphemism a joke and it was
people would have sent to them shampoo
bottles perhaps with a little bourbon in
it
uh but it was quite guarded this is very
obvious as you know because most
everyone here has some sort of
relationship or
with alcohol it's very hard to hide
alcohol use you know the odor so
i remember one snake bite kit being
broken out on a warship that i was on
but they literally locked the doors and
someone said i just got bit by a [ __ ]
snake
and pulled out a bottle and everyone got
like a couple of shots and that was it
on a 10-month deployment
there wasn't much alcohol there at all
but
there are many other drugs out there
and there's a deep hypocrisy
that you would see in how the military
our military and western militaries in
general relate with drugs
in their own forces versus into their
allied forces and what i mean by that is
since
the failed hostage rescue attempt laid
in the carter administration uh in which
drug use was given part of the blame
uh for the failure for the mechanical
failure of the aircraft there was a
story that circulated in the military in
the years after
that a
sailor had been smoking pot in a hangar
deck and had caused a small fire in a
garbage can and this had activated a
sprinkler system which had sprayed some
salt water on some of the aircraft and
this was considered perhaps a culprit in
one of the aircraft's failures on the
mission
whether the story is apocryphal i
haven't done the deep dive research to
tell you but it was widely trafficked
when i was in and we as a result
had gone to a service
um that coming out of vietnam used
marijuana very heavily that now had drug
testing
routine regular urinalysis sometimes
randomized
you know they would do things like take
a a unit and pull numbers out of a hat
and say if your social security ends in
five or seven then you all have to
report to the first sergeant for your
analysis today and it was not quite zero
tolerance you were given two chances but
you would be prosecuted on the first
chance and discharge on the first hit
and discharged on the second
with a negative discharge that could
affect you for the rest of your life
so the use of marijuana really fell off
in the 80s
in our force
in the western forces
but when you go to the battlefields now
you will find the allies may be heavily
using
and some of you said that your book
is horror over comedy some of the scenes
i saw in afghanistan you would qualify
as comedy there would be tents alongside
each other
with americans or western forces and one
and the afghan partners in the other and
the americans would all be dipping
copenhagen which is a um
a tobacco snuff that basically tastes
like cow [ __ ]
but it's incredibly popular because and
it's very useful but it's hands-free and
it's smokeless so people can take it on
patrols or you can operate a vehicle a
rifle
a radio any number of things with it you
don't have to fumble with matches
and so it's immensely popular so
everyone in the american tent likely be
using tobacco and some caffeine monsters
and rippets were immensely popular
and in the afghan tent
literally smoke billowing out of it
from hashish or marijuana hashish use
was universal i would say among the
afghan units maybe not among every
afghan but in every unit it was
impossible not to smell it not to see it
it was openly used and of course there's
traffic between the two tents so many of
the americans were going into the afghan
tent and getting high
and then episodically
we'll call it provincially depending on
which province an american service
member might be assigned to
uh the agriculture afghans got a lot of
different afghanistan has many different
climates so it has many different
uh agricultural products and in some
areas some regions of afghanistan
marijuana
um
is grown
extensively and so if you're in the
mountains you wouldn't see
this marijuana growing but if you were
down in the
irrigated step you would see massive
marijuana fields and troops would patrol
it and through it and pick it and many
of them would smoke it and i know some
units that had heavy marijuana use
so heavy that the commanders kind of had
to wink at it and be careful about
not having drug tests because they would
have had to discharge the entire unit uh
or punish the entire unit and there's
one story that's related to me by a
close friend of mine who was in the core
i was a journalist at this point often
with the marine corps but
this former marine you know was a urine
donor when the test came along he was
clean and he would donate urine to his
uh friends particularly in the mortar
pit
the mortar unit was
high all the time basically a baked
mortar unit and he would donate his
urine
so that his friends wouldn't get
hammered
you know by the rules
but hash and pot
while they were
you know very common on the battlefield
were mostly isolated to the afghans and
this creates situations of hypocrisy
where we on the one hand have something
like a zero tolerance policy for our
force
but our allies are openly actively
extensively
using it
when you bring it forward as you talked
about drugs after war
marijuana has a significant place in the
conversation now
the government again has a set of
policies that don't align with the human
behaviors
of the population the government serves
and what i mean by that is veterans come
home
and they go to the va and many of the
veterans have a number of problems in
which substances
whether illicitly obtained or legally
prescribed
are seen as part of the common remedy
and the va will prescribe all manner of
drugs
to the former rank and file to the
veterans antidepressants mood
stabilizers opiates for pain
but because marijuana is a
stage i'm sorry schedule one controlled
substance by the dea federally the va
cannot administer
marijuana even though jurisdictionally
many veterans live in states like rhode
island that have medical marijuana
programs that make marijuana quite
accessible legally and the va won't deny
care to someone who's using marijuana a
veteran but they cannot be involved in
the prescription
which creates
pretty disheartening circumstances for
many veterans i know veterans who live
in states that don't have medical
marijuana and they risk legal action
going out and getting it on the street
i'm not here to say marijuana is a
necessarily you know a universal panacea
for many of the afflictions that
veterans suffer when they come home
because i think the science on that is
mixed and individual experiences really
vary for some people find it helps and
others don't
and self-prescription has um
uh its pitfalls was very hard to get it
regulated just right in a way that you
know a consistently produced
pharmaceutical uh product is more easy
to to regulate because the product is
the same from event to event from dose
to dose
so i'm not here to advocate the
marijuana position but i am to say here
to say that it's deeply confusing for
veterans that they are heavily
prescribed with opiates and other drugs
but do not have any formal counseling on
the use of medical marijuana which many
of them find
alleviates their symptoms and i would
add that opiates and veterans some of
the studies have shown can lead to you
know like twice the rate of overdose
among the veteran population so it is a
fair question to say how responsible
this policy is
for the administration of the medical
care of our veterans
when they have this access and you could
argue encouragement to use opiates which
they feel with some justification and
data in their corner
much more dangerous than marijuana and
my 10 minutes are up
and it's your turn
[Applause]
well first of all i have to say that i'm
very happy to be here today so i
graduated here and it's it's just
fantastic to be home um i was peter's a
student so needless to say i'm honored
to be commenting his book today um his
work had an enormous intellectual
influence on me uh in the work i do so
needless to say i like his book um and
uh as i have enjoyed his other books but
i have always admired peter's
intellectual rigor and the ability that
he has to tackle big questions but in
clear simple language and i think that
that's like in his other books in this
book that's very clear this is a book
that is a presenter for a wider audience
and i think that uh like paul gutenberg
says in the jacket of the book this is
the work of a public intellectual uh but
with with analytic rigor and i think
that's um
that's something that characterizes your
work and i think that makes it fabulous
um i think this book also builds on and
continues things that peter has already
explored in his previous books and in
his previous work and i will say
naturally he mentions it at the end of
the book but there are like three main
three main blocks that i think are in
this book and that appear in his the
rest of his work uh the first one is
this
call to basically go back to history to
think about problems of violence of
illicit markets um and i think that's a
big that's a that's an important
such an important thing because we tend
to
exaggerate anything that has to do with
violence anything that has to elicit
markets with drugs
so peter's ability to go back to history
and show us that
problems that we tend to consider with
us and you are never new and actually
have deep rooted
history is very important the second
point that i think is part of his work
and appears here again
is how the state plays such an important
role in creating and recreating the
problems that it aims to solve
so the state is a very important
protagonist is this book as it has been
in others of peter's works which is
essential again because when we think
about illicit markets when we think
about specially especially especially
today we think of non-state actors and
the state tends to be like to thought
about something that is isolated and
peter's work really has been i think
influential for many people like me to
really think about the state as deeply
immersed in the dynamics of illicit
markets and in the dynamics of violence
i think the third
element that is clear in this book that
has been
and cleared in others of peter's works
is that
he really has this ability to question
simple and simplistic and exaggerated
ideas and he does it elegantly and he
has it very effectively
and those all those elements are present
in this book i think that this book is
taking on on
questioning another conventional wisdom
and peter mentioned it at the beginning
which is this historic amnesia about the
way we think about new wars
and i think he's implicitly taking
uh with a debate with this literature um
and i'm sure you probably want to atta
like take a disciplinary debate but in
political science and i think outside of
political science very influential
leaders are talking about new wars and
how after the end of the in the collapse
of the soviet union what we have seen is
the emergence of this kind of wars that
are mostly non-state that tend to be
brutal that things that tend to be
unregulated irrational and that they
tend to be mostly motivated by profit um
in this whole grid ingredients debate
which is basically the idea that many of
the wars that we see inside the states
are mostly motivated because of it is it
profits and i think that pierre is
implicitly taking on a debate against
his literature by by telling us hey this
relationship between illicit drugs and
war is not just about non-state actors
um and it's not just about you know
crazy armies uh in developing countries
and i think that that's a key
a key part of this book um
and
so peter is showing us that this
connection between wars and drugs is
very old is multifaceted um and that it
permeates not only these drugs of today
but of course the drugs that we probably
will never will never admit that we are
addicted to coffee as a drug right and
and peter really
i think challenges us to think about
coffee alongside this other
more
negatively seeing drugs like like
cocaine or methamphetamines or opium um
and and in some ways coffee is is the
one that seems to be like the like the
oldest bird in this book because just
because if we think about alcohol
nicotine
methamphetamines opium and cocaine those
are drugs that have like
bigger psychoactive effects and um and
they are not as widely used but i think
peter really
like is able to convince us that coffee
does belong in this group
and that it does belong because
the way that it expanded is tightly
connected to war and to war making uh in
that history of war really of coffee
drinking really we coming and taking um
becoming widespread really after war is
fascinating um the the history of
coca-cola in the book is also
fascinating how basically
the brand really becomes much more
popular because of of war and i think
that that's
that's a fascinating story and it is one
that really kind of pushes us to think
like
coffee does really belong in this
history because it's a psychoactive
substance and it's a psychoactive
substance that has expanded through war
um in that
and that has influenced the behavior of
people in wars so i think that that's
very interesting there is a short
mention about coffee in central america
um which i think is very important too
right like showing that
that in in certain places the way that
these drugs are being produced and the
way that they are being um
the property around the production of
these drugs can also be uh
a source of work what he calls that the
war
through drugs right um
and
so i have to say that in that regard one
of the most fascinating chapters i mean
every chapter in this book is
fascinating but i love the chapter of
methamphetamines
because there is so much there that is
new and it's interesting um and so
basically just peter is telling us this
story about how methamphetamines and the
use of methamphetamines has was really
spread through wars especially world war
ii um in in that history i think
hasn't been told well until now when
he's kind of putting it together and
telling it
and thinking about how we compare and
think about these six drugs
i think the comparison between cocaine
methamphetamines and opium is really
interesting
so one thing and one construct that i
found really fascinating when reading
the book is the fact that cocaine and
methamphetamines are very similar in
many regards
they have you can say in some ways they
are comparable
in the types of effects they create on
the users
they are also comparable in the sense
that there is not as much widespread use
as you will see in alcohol or in tobacco
yet they end up having two very
different um destinies right so
methamphetamines take off right after
world war ii but the fate of cocaine is
being
illegal and becoming successful as an
illegal market but be kind of becoming
completely separated from the state
and i think for the discussion it would
just be interesting to hear more from
you about why you think that's the case
because there is i don't think
there are i think there are some
potential explanations but it's actually
not straightforward you will think well
maybe there were more influence from the
from the pharmaceutical companies in
methamphetamine production that was part
of the story but pharmaceutical
companies also played a very important
role with cocaine especially at the
beginning of the century so i think that
that's a really interesting question
that came up to me as i was reading the
book um
i think another common thread throughout
the book
um
is and and again this is something that
i think echoes peter's previous work is
the paradoxes
of the role of the state in regulating
these markets and intervening here um
and and i think peter shows really well
that that there is never like kind of a
clear black and white story about who's
the good and the in these stories and i
think that's always very useful when
we're thinking about war and when we're
thinking about illicit markets so he
chose in many ways how bands have always
ended up being very unsuccessful right
so we think about the the bans on or the
war on drugs but it's more than that
right so he shows the ultimate failure
of different bands from the band of
tobacco in persia or in japan in the
1600s to the venom coffee houses
by king charles ii in 1675 for different
reasons right and all those end up being
unsuccessful because there is a strong
pushback from the peop from the users
but also from the people who
are profiting from those markets
and and of course inevitably that takes
us to today and thinking okay there is
so much debate right now about drug
reform
but we keep we talk mostly about
marijuana right and i think there is a
reason for that and is the fact that
there is
there is more widespread use right like
like the constituencies are different
and as much as i was reading the book
and i was saying yeah like we have an
entire history of bands
failing to do what they intend to do and
that can be applied to the war on drugs
today but at the same time it doesn't
seem that
whatever brought those bands to an end
before can be applied at least for the
hardest drugs to heroin and cocaine
today um so i was just kind of again
another another
another idea for for thinking about like
think knowing what we know from this
history of wars and drugs
and knowing what we know about how
basically what ends up happening after
many of these words is that there is a
push for them to move forward because
there are not not enough forces to keep
them control
but that doesn't seem to be the case
that that's going to happen to cocaine
ever i think so or to heroin so it will
be just interesting to hear about it um
i think i don't know how i'm doing on
time but i i'm just i'm gonna be close
to finish here um another thing that was
very
interesting uh from this book and i
think peter never says it like openly is
what i tend to do but he doesn't i think
for a reason which is the focus on
major powers um
in in
in history but basically on major wars
and major powers uh there are some
references to developing countries at
different points throughout the book but
release is a history of how major powers
western powers but not only western
china russia like the major powers in
the world have been a kind of a central
part of this story and i think this is
essential because this is really what
challenges this narrative that we have
that is driven by what has happened in
the last two or three decades which is a
story of non-state actors and developing
countries but really in the long run of
history it's a story about major powers
uh in major wars and wars between states
um so i think that that's a very i think
that's a driving force of how peter
chose the cases that appear in this book
but i'm kind of curious also to hear
more about how you ended up choosing the
stories that that appear in this book
because i'm sure you had a lot of
stories to choose from and one thing
that is fascinating about this book is
that i'm highlighting ideas but i'm also
highlighting stories because the pieces
of the stories that appear in this book
is the kind of thing that i don't wanna
you wanna tell in a cocktail party or in
a class saying okay this is this is what
will lead you to think different about
the relationship between wars and drugs
um
and
so
so yeah i think that was my i would have
to say that i love the idea of calling
um
great britain the first narco state and
and it's a it's a statement and i think
it's a very important statement and i
wanted to close just one with one last
question and one last reflection which
is
as i said at the beginning i think one
of the major contributions from peter's
work is this push to look back to
history to really rethink and question
some of the ways in which we think about
current problems um
and i think personally
i see how when we go back to history and
see that things that we think are new
are not so new give us a lot of elements
to think okay what mistakes not to make
again or
it really provides a lot of food for
thought but also a lot of
elements to rethink how we
think about problems that are major
today
at the same time i've kind of faced
skepticism from people sometimes saying
you know you
like yeah we can look back to history
but we don't care about history we care
about what's in the future and you have
been you look back to history but you
are engaged in policy discussions and i
just want to hear a little bit of how
people react or how you try to connect
this when what you're talking about and
you're asked to provide
policy
policy recommendations or policy ideas
and i will stop that thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm eager to hear more from peter as i'm
sure most of you are so let me just make
a few brief comments um what i
was most impressed about from this book
even goes beyond the subject matter
which is the whole approach of
trying to look at history in a new way
that's one of the most exciting parts of
the business that we're in facts don't
change but we understand facts
differently as time passes and we get to
a rearrange facts that's one of the
thrilling parts of our job and that's i
think the great
category of research into which this
book uh
fits it gives us a new way to understand
where we've been and and where we are
now
um
we understand from this book that drugs
are both a tool of war and also a reason
for war i think the combination of those
two uh highlights the importance of this
theme um i want to pick up on something
that chris said he used the word
hypocrisy
and that's something that's a theme that
shines right through this book in so
many different ways
i would go build on what chris said and
said there's also a tremendous hypocrisy
in the way governments deal with drugs
on the one hand denouncing and
condemning them on the other hand using
them as tools for their own political
purposes internationally
we
use
uh those drugs not only as motivations
but as inspirations for what we can get
what's out there for us and how we can
get it
this hypocrisy
extends to
our
tolerance of
drug traffickers from other countries
just as we decide which countries we
don't like and then we figure out oh
that must be a terrorist and we find a
way to make them into a terrorist and
other terrorists who we like we go out
bend over backwards to try to pretend
that they're actually paladins of
democracy the same thing happens with
with drug lords
i had a vivid experience i'll never
forget with one of my favorite drug
lords one of the first one of the only
ones that i really got to know and that
was manuel noriega the panamanian leader
in the 1980s i'll never forget having an
interview with noriega
and uh
telling him a little bit uncomfortably
but that's my job as a reporter that
there's been many reports uh that you've
been deeply involved in drug trafficking
and therefore it's i have to ask you how
do you respond
to those reports and so he kind of
smiled and he gestured over one of his
aides and the aide had a a briefcase
noriega looks through and he pulls out
from a folder and a letter and he hands
it over to me and the letter
is on the letterhead of the drug
enforcement administration and it says
dear general noriega we want to thank
you so much for all the help you've
given us in controlling the drug traffic
in the caribbean basin signed john long
director
of the drug enforcement administration
now if we all knew noriega was a drug
trafficker the dea certainly knew but
noriega had a great game going he was
working for one cartel
and when the other cartel would try to
use panama he would find out about it
and call the dea they would then be able
to boast of a great big bust and at the
meanwhile noriega was
funneling large amounts of cocaine with
the full knowledge i'm sure of the dea
through other channels
also in the 1980s i remember sitting in
nicaragua where i was living then there
were a lot of reports that the santa
nices were financing their war in part
by shipping cocaine out and that the
contras were doing the same thing we
didn't have the detailed information to
speculate or to report on that but when
we spoke among ourselves our answer
always was how could they not
it's a poor country you need lots of
money you've got a fantastic market with
piles of money just a few miles away on
an illicit plane flight so i have no
doubt that uh that was a substantial
contributor to the wars in central
america
um i think those of us that have seen
combat
understand that war is much more chaotic
than it sometimes seems to be when
you're watching it in movies or when
you're reading about it um
the act of going out and participating
in a war
violates so many deep instincts and
impulses and principles
inside every human being
i i do think this might be one of the
reasons why drugs become important
the reality of war is too awful to face
so these drugs actually help people
face
something that in a normal life you
wouldn't want to face and you wouldn't
want to be able to face but it's very
important for governments that soldiers
be able to face themselves i think that
helps
uh
wipe away any objections that governing
forces might have
to the use of those drugs uh chris also
mentioned vietnam and it's absolutely
true that was a turning point in the u.s
military that's when uh we not only went
from uh
a very drug-fueled military to uh one
that was drug controlled through
urinalysis but that was also not
coincidentally the time when we moved
away from a volunteer army towards i'm
sorry from a draftee army to a voluntary
army
this is another
big
result
of drug use in the military and the fact
that we now have an all-volunteer army
is definitely a great enabling factor
for our government when it wants to
prosecute wars because a lot easier to
do so needless to say when people are
not worried about the draft
um
when i first started the book i was
wondering why peter didn't use sugar as
one of his drugs but then when i got to
the rum part i came to realize yeah he
did use sugar it's just it wrapped up in
an even larger
uh drug uh
in my last book i wrote about u.s army
efforts to develop lsd as a weapon of
war and they actually had the idea that
they could dump huge amounts of it on
enemy populations and everybody would
love them and they would think their
rifles were hydrangeas and that the
enemy was just their blood relatives and
they wouldn't shoot at them uh but
actually this turned out not to work
that's the reason it's not in this book
the the
actions
uh the effects of lsd too unpredictable
to be used effectively as a as a weapon
of war
um
i
also think that this uh
combination of factors that peter has
so brilliantly highlighted in this book
still play out today in many ways
from very small to very big i've been
told by
intelligence officers that worked in
afghanistan trying to pick out which are
the huts that they have to have night
raids against because somebody's living
in there that we want to get one of the
things they tell them is as your
intelligence guy is walking through the
village
look and see if there are huts where
there's no cigarette butts outside
that's probably somebody in the taliban
so the taliban might have picked up on
that by now maybe they distribute
cigarette butts to people to distribute
drop outside their homes but that was
certainly a factor and i want to go on
and also mention the fact that one of
our principal foreign policy tools now
as has been for several decades are
sanctions we like to sanction
governments so they can't freely export
or import their economies are greatly
constricted
so i've lived personally through two
strong episodes of this that i covered
in yugoslavia
and then again in iraq
those were both situations in which
governments were pressed to move towards
illegal sources of income and because of
sanctions those governments turned in
part to drug trafficking and there's no
better example of this than north korea
which is a major industrial exporter of
illegal drugs and it does so largely
because it's not able to have other
kinds of economic activity um
we certainly wouldn't want to uh
ignore the role of uh opium and other
drugs in building up new england and
building up our economy it was a the
trade
from new england merchants that provided
the capital for all the factories that
made new england such a such a world
power
so from this book i take away uh a new
lens and looking at history just to give
one example so i i spend some time
thinking about and writing about iran
why does iran have a government like it
does today well there was a revolution
40 years ago why did that revolution
happen because people felt that the old
government was not respecting their
democracy where did the idea of their
democracy came from come from it came
from the 1906 constitutional revolution
in iran what set off the constitutional
revolution in iran the tobacco revolt
it was when
the british insisted and the shah of
iran being brought by the british agreed
to
uh monopole to give the british company
a british tobacco company monopoly
control over the entire tobacco industry
and forbid every iranian from growing or
producing or selling tobacco that an
explosion happened even the harem women
the shah's harem women
refused to smoke as a result of the
fatwa handed down by the leading
religious figure in iran so if you trace
it all back
the entire crisis in iran
was set off
by
rebellion about tobacco
once you begin to realize that you
understand how much of history remains
to be explained in a new way and how
valuable are people whose insights are
such that they allow us to find a new
lens to understand circumstances that we
thought we already understood and for
that i really applaud you peter thank
you
[Applause]
floor's open um
sorry
no one told us
on the panel that has lavishly
illustrated this book through pictures
and so forth you tell the story but i
this is a point that several people
mentioned implicitly
incredible irony complexity history
is that you want us to take home a
message the only messages i can get are
don't go to war and stop the hypocrisy
but you might have something a little
bit more what what would you what would
you advise
countries having learned and studied so
deeply this history
right to the policy implications yeah
watson institute
right
should i go ahead and answer all right
i have to say of all the things i've
written
this is the book where
i'm more stumped than usual on sort of
what the
actual direct explicit policy
recommendation is because a radical one
would be
if you
actually take seriously
that you don't want illicit drugs
funding terrorists and insurgents and
traffickers who have private armies
is drug legalization
i mean that's a logical conclusion one
can reach from this book i don't go
there but it's a understandable
avenue of inquiry because the source of
the funding today
is illicit drugs
uh drugs that at one point history
weren't illicit but the more illicit the
drug becomes
the more it's the domain of profiteering
by non-state actors
and the less it's taxable by authorities
historically authorities have used drug
revenue to pay for armies and all sorts
of things but now it's warlords the
taliban insurgents terrorists and so on
so
if that's your priority the war on
terror the war traffickers
it's legalization but obviously the
legalization debate is much more
complicated than than that and so for
example
cannabis legalization which has
moved the farthest including places like
rhode island but also especially north
of here massachusetts and elsewhere
it helps but it's it's not the major
funder of of
violence and insurgents and the way that
cocaine and opium is
in the back
so we can get to the second one ready
i'm sorry what get a second one so we
can give them
sure
uh i haven't read the book
i'm sorry go ahead
okay i haven't read the book um
so i don't know
everything's in there but there's copies
outside i do want to congratulate you on
uh
parsing the myriad ways in which wars
and drugs intersect
uh but i have a comment and a question
comment i was a little surprised nobody
mentioned the etymological basis of the
words assassin and assassination which
is hashish
probably in your book but my question
goes back to
how often
and the opium wars are
the prime example but how often
are drugs
the
either overt or or covert
reason for
a particular war and i'm not talking
about non-state entities but actual
nation states or
equivalent right
um just on the first thing you mentioned
hashish and assassins it's a famous
story uh i don't include it
partly because there's actually debate
over there whether it's pure myth
but it's it's it's just part of folklore
and so
i don't go there because the evidence is
thin and in fact much of the discussion
of it is that it's a mythical story that
people like to tell
the second question
or actually your main question
is
one of the relationships that i
unpack and and identify as
war for drugs
and
this is where i think it's very
important to distinguish between war for
drugs versus war through drugs because
in the current policy debate and this
gets to jim's issue with policy
discussions
i actually think
war through drugs overwhelms the
importance of war for drugs both
historically
and today there's always exceptions and
it varies in range but for the most part
drugs have been this extraordinarily
potent
potent literally a facilitator
of warfare but the cases where you can
really point to an explicit that that's
why they went to war
with drugs are much more rare so the
opium wars are the first things to comes
to mind
but there's a reason that we always fall
back on the opium wars as the sort of
prime historical
uh example of this but all the way up to
the present i think today it's
the war
for drugs is largely in the realm of
illicit drugs and it's
largely in places such as
mexico
peter i i also have a question about
opium wars partly because i taught it
this morning
not the china side of it as much as the
t opm connection
under east india company and your
description that british maritime power
was mobilized to support um a private
company so there was a
interesting combination here between
state power
and private power um um
and for the two opium wars now the
question is this
the data that has emerged from
economic uh history over the last 40
years and most of it out of economic
history as a sub-discipline in america
is dead
but economic history continues to be a
vibrant discipline in europe so there
are new estimates
that have emerged about the proportion
of let's say manufacturing
world manufacturing in different parts
of the world
agricultural data for 1700 or 1600 is
virtually impossible to estimate
right but manufacturing has been
estimated
so here is what we have about
what happened to china
after opium wars i'm not claiming that
opm wars led to the decline of
chinese economy but just to give you
some sense of what the correlations are
not causality
until 1800
china produced one-third of the the
world's entire manufacturing output
until 1800.
and what we call the west today had only
one-fourth of the world's manufacturing
output
by 1860 which is when the second opium
war is more or less ending china is down
to 19.7 and then there's a steep decline
after the second opium war and china
share a world's manufacturing output by
1900 is 6.2
down from 33 in 1800 to 6.2 in 1900
whereas the what we call the west again
it rises from
from 18.2 in 1750 to 77.4 in 1900.
the question is this
are there other examples you know
where
wars over drugs
either led to or were correlated with
such steep economic declines as we saw
in china
and notice even in the chinese
literature or chinese popular discourse
this whole idea of 100 years of
humiliation
begins with the opium wars and the
decline that china saw after the after
the two opium wars are there other such
cases of steeped economic decline
correlated with if not caused by
by
wars over drugs
there may be but i can't think of a case
that's remotely close to as extreme a
case
having said that
i'm wary of
pointing to
a unitary causal relationship between
those outcomes that you point to and
opium um it's correlation as you teach
and no is not causation opium is a
culprit
but one of the lessons of this book
after the you know the book hits you
over the head on the importance of drugs
in relationship to war
at the end of the day
there is a warning to readers saying
uh i'd also don't want you to drug the
analysis
it's not drugs drugs drugs right so i'm
wary of basically saying look what
happened to china during the hundred
years after the opium wars it's all
because of opium it's a lot more
complicated than that but opium is
certainly a culprit and an important
culprit and one thing fascinating about
the opium wars is that after the second
opium war china actually threw in the
towel so much
that it basically did import
substitution industrialization it
basically became itself
the largest producer of opium in the
world it said we can't beat we can't
beat uh we can't keep out uh indian
imports of
of of opium we'll just legalize the
stuff and produce it ourselves so at the
turn of the century by 1900 china's the
world's largest consumer and producer
of of opium but
the
economic decline that you point to first
of all
you know it's relative to other places
rising
um so that's also problematic um but
opium certainly
uh
a big culprit but i would say the most
important impact of opium on china
is
chinese identity and the
psychology of thinking of being poisoned
by the outside world and
anti-imperialism has basically paved the
way for the chinese revolution in a
substantial way
oh i should add
one of the biggest losers of the chinese
revolution is opium
china led the most
sweeping draconian and most effective
war against drugs the world has ever
seen
basically virtually wiped out opium from
china
given its previous hundred year history
and it's precisely for that reason that
the drug moves south into the golden
triangle of southeast asia
thank you all for sharing um
i
personally immediately jumped when i
started hearing about killer high to the
60s
and the role of especially lsd and the
anti-drug movement and i think today
we're seeing their surgeons have a lot
of those ideas of the 60s especially
when it comes to hallucinogenic drugs
both marijuana the new breakthrough
status on both psilocybin mushrooms as
well as on mdma
and i just love your perspective on how
do hallucinogenic drugs of the 60s and
all the way up to today sort of fit into
that discussion
great question um
you know i explain in the introduction
why i pick certain drugs and why i
actually largely ignore other drugs so
it's a history of war in six drugs not
seven or eight or nine
and
hallucinogenic drugs don't make the cut
and for all sorts of reasons some of
which you might imagine they're not
particularly
effective on the battlefield
states have never figured out how to
tax them and make revenue it's a there
tend to be very niche drugs
and as you mentioned in some cases
kind of considered an
anti-war drug that was certainly true of
cannabis uh in the 60s
stephen kinser has shown in his most
recent book so brilliantly as it was
certainly researched and experimented on
as a mind control drug and as a weapon
of of war by the cia but that still
didn't rise it to the status of a sort
of globally commercialized mass
consumption popular profit profitable
drug the way these others are
one thing that i think is going to grow
in importance is um
chris mentioned returning
uh gis and and turning to various drugs
and coping with the aftermath of war
well there's actually growing research
showing that you know one of the most
effective treatments for ptsd is
basically micro dosing of mdma
and
there's a push to get the da to
reschedule it and and be able to use it
for medical purposes i don't know
how far that's going to get or whether
we can project in the future but frankly
sitting here 10 years just 10 years ago
no one would have predicted the
legalization of marijuana so it's
possible that actually
we'll see a proliferation of what you
just described as the present moment
again peter it's such provocative work i
really love it uh but let me ask you to
make some comparisons to two other kinds
of addictions that don't involve
psychoactive substances as far as i know
so you know what we do talk about the
addiction to oil
and conflicts surrounding oil and what
are the parallels maybe they don't exist
between
drug wars and oil related wars of course
they're both resource related but i'm
interested in those parallels but also
maybe a different kind of addiction
social media facebook kind of the juice
you get from this the ability of of that
kind of commerce to manipulate people
and we're seeing now cause conflict
potentially between countries so are can
you draw parallels across
psychoactive substances in war
uh energy resources oil and war and a
different kind of commercial product
whatever it is social media
great question i don't go there in the
book i could perhaps in the conclusion
make these kind of um
linkages and perhaps i should have um
i
one dimension of the relationship
between war and drugs is what i
emphasize war through drugs and and
another one is war iv drugs and those
are the two dimensions where you can
most clearly see well
it's just yet another example of
resource wars right so oil war for oil
or through oil right so in that regard
it's part of a larger universe of using
profitable commodities
to generate revenue for war making not a
particularly
unfamiliar story but a hugely important
one right um
so
i think as stephen kinser said you know
in central america they were like well
it's the most profitable thing going
well that's what they'll use in the in
the in the 1980s um so why wouldn't they
so in that sense there's a pragmatism
you use whatever revenue on whatever
commodities available regardless of the
legal status of the things so the oil
comparison
um
comparing it to sort of the other things
you mentioned social media
um i think there's a terrific data and
surveillance yeah
um
i'll punt a little bit and say david
court writes a new book he's probably
one of the better known um drug
historians just has a new book out last
year so called the age of addiction
and it basically does take this big
ambitious sweep at sort of
you know the modern world in terms of
the various things we're addicted to
including video games and
and so on um i don't go there uh but um
it's provocative reading and i certainly
recommend it um to others that i do
conclude the book one thing i do go out
on a limb a little bit in the last
page of the book
is to say you know i've talked about all
these relationships between war and
drugs
but maybe we should also think of war
itself
war as drug
right because actually
some of the psychoactive effects of war
ins
can be considered drug like
the adrenaline rush anyone seen the hurt
locker i mean you know that is a case of
of addiction right he basically shot at
the end of the movie he's back in
suburbia shopping at the store you know
he's and then he goes and re-enlists
right others um you know war journalists
who've you know
gone out uh chris hedges has actually
you know wrote a book very basically
literally describes the rush of of war
as a drug and there's plenty of memoirs
and diaries from soldiers to generals
sort of describing the effect
as the equivalent of addiction
or for maybe one or two more questions
and if it
was thrown back
[Music]
thank you
um okay so
i guess to keep it brief uh the question
that i was holding on to was if there
was anybody
that was doing anything with addiction
science like if you had to name one
person that was doing something
revolutionary there
there would be you know where you'd find
something else
um like some other approach to the idea
of addiction that you find maybe
clinically or just generally written
about i guess and that might be mr court
david corwright book called the age of
addiction he's a historian but he so he
takes it all the way back uh
centuries but he brings it right to the
present
um
but i would
i would not point to one person as sort
of the the addiction
expert
expert
there's there's enormous literature on
this i do know that
there is a considerable amount of
research going on and there should be a
lot more funded in terms of the nature
of addiction and
you know the the very idea of an
addiction vaccine interestingly enough
for some drugs is is
is a possibility down the road but um so
i don't have a name for you
unfortunately
oh well right on i guess i meant to
recognize that it already sort of been
answered in the last question which was
sort of satisfying and yeah very
grateful for that and um
there was one other bit yeah i guess the
effect of the opium war on china and
that and looking at the causality of
opium and it just yeah i guess it's a
comment too that it just seemed it was
more like the if anything was the cause
it would have been the war
it would have been war not drugs that
had been the cause and sort of war
through drugs and then it just seemed
that you almost
drugged war
in the last bit by saying that looking
at war as a drug they're saying yeah i
just remember coming like and try not to
drug something uh maybe drug the
analysis so i just found that
interesting i don't know so yeah
thank you so much
i'm just curious about your explanation
for the methamphetamine versus cocaine
story oh right yes
maybe we should conclude by letting the
panelist say something um
uh i appreciate pushing you pushing me
on that it's
that was that your great question why
cocaine did not take off on the
battlefield the way methamphetamines did
it actually made an appearance in world
war ii
um
and there's plenty of evidence of it but
then
major states turn against cocaine led by
the u.s but britain did too
to basically move against uh cocaine
including with soldier use i mean
simulant freud was was a big fan of
cocaine and and he basically first
became aware of it because the germans
were testing it on soldiers
uh and thought it was this magical
wonder drug
um it's a perfect example of it's much
easier to identify
how something changed
and that it changed factually versus
why
exactly because cocaine basically
because of it becomes more criminalized
status in the 20th century
therefore
much less used
uh for functional purposes on on the on
the battlefield in fact now that i now
that you asked me about this
there were efforts
suggestions that that that the the u.s
military study
the positive effects of coca
on uh enter you know mild and you know
basically the raw material for for
cocaine but you know it's basic it's
very mild stimulant
and the use of such an anti-drug mode
that it squashed any research on coca
even though
for many centuries you know peruvian
soldiers had
found it to be incredible energy
boosting and uh hunger reducing
um
so um
it does open the door for amphetamines
because basically amphetamines
in fact you know
uh
in fact what's interesting is when
amphetamines become criminalized
in the u.s in the 1960s that's actually
when cocaine
takes off because a lot of people do
turn to cocaine recreationally when
amphetamines become less much less
available
uh well my one comment is uh
something that you mentioned the it's
nice when the book has its high point on
the last page
uh and i agree with that observation
about war was a drug but i would say
from my perspective yeah it is a drug it
is addictive for some people on the
battlefield including people that are
fighting and people uh that are watching
the fighting
but i also think it's addictive at a
higher level it's addictive for the
generals it's addictive for the
politicians it's such a great
political benefit it pays off in so many
ways the promotion of war
so i feel that that addiction to war at
that level is actually uh more
pernicious even than the individual
addiction of war to people that are
actually seeing it unfold
it all depends how we define addiction
of course but anyway and from the public
too right like the consumption of
violence is so high in the media
now i will just say and with inviting
everybody to read it um it's a i
mentioned i didn't say this when i was
talking but i assigned your work because
it's very easy for students to read and
still get a very deep understanding of
things and your last comment to my
question just makes me think that
geopolitics still plays such an
important role and maybe the reason why
cocaine ended up the way it did in
methamphetamine is because coca was
coming from latin america mostly so that
there was a like a very deeply
invaluable relation there so but thank
you so much chris
so i'm not a historian but i'm an
observer and chronicler of modern
military activity
and this book is very valuable for that
and sort of underlined
some of my own experiences i mean if you
really want to see
there's many sort of angles of inquiry
to
observe and document the failures of the
modern american military one of the
surefire places though to do this one of
the themes to look at
is in its work against drugs in
afghanistan
i mean it was astonishing one of the
surest ways to get in a gun fight in
afghanistan was to go out with a unit
doing counter-narcotics work
this was not ideological
it was practical because to go and try
to burn a poppy field is to uh
essentially impact
um a hillbilly economy with top cover
and so the american military realized
this pretty quickly at the operational
level down at the the field commanders
and they stopped doing it they tolerated
it
although there still was officially
an effort to reduce the amount of opium
poppy production in afghanistan at the
practical level most units knew better
than to try
they didn't want to lose people to this
and lose a lot of people and
there was a
doctrinal
contradiction in that counter-insurgency
you're supposed to get along with the
local population but if you're attacking
the local population's wartime economy
which was often opium based
because opium unlike tomatoes or melons
is an enduring product that you can hold
on to until the road is open it's not
perishable
and so naturally in a war climate opium
was being grown very heavily in the
areas that
could grow opium uh because of climate
and water access
and the americans just left it alone or
they would engage in as the american
military often does activities that look
like accomplishment but actually are not
so you could go see opium fields being
burned
but the fields already would have been
harvested
and
and there there'd be no gunfight because
they would pay the farmer to let the
field be burned but he'd already removed
his product and you're burning the
stubble and that was a very safe patrol
to go on
it was also a farce
an absolute farce
and it was a common one
and you could also find very reliably in
the areas where opium was being grown
places where it would be almost
certainly grown and that was inside the
grounds of an afghan police station
and that's just kind of how the way it
was and this book brings that home
really well and uh and i i commend and
recommend it both
thank you there's books outside
i also want to thank everybody just
remind you there's a reception outside
so again chris chivers
angelica duran martinez stephen kinser
and of course peter andreas thank you
[Applause]
book tv continues now on c-span 2.